[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue non point de
vue c'est un plaisir de vous retrouver
comme chaque jour pour échanger des
points de vue de préférences
contradictoires sur deux thèmes
d'actualité en compagnie de nos invités
bonsoir chloé morin on est très heureux
de vous accueillir dans un point de vue
vous êtes politologue associé à la
fondation jean jaurès
votre dernier livre les inamovibles de
la république et sous titré de façon
intrigante vous ne les verrez jamais
mais ils gouvernent eux c'est ce sont
les hauts fonctionnaires cette haute
fonction publique que donald trump
appelle l'état profond ça a été publié
aux éditions de l'aube
et j'ajoute que vous avez collaboré au
cabinet de deux premiers ministres jean
marc ayrault et manuel valls
bon soit gabriel cluzet nommé treize
heureux de vous retrouver en ce début
d'année vous êtes la rédactrice en chef
du site boulevard voltaire un site bien
ancrée à droite on peut le dire on peut
le dire est votre dernier livre enraciné
nous sommes tous d héritier a été
publiée aux éditions artège je propose
de commencer avec ce séminaire
gouvernemental convoqué par le président
de la république avec un certain nombre
de ministres on y parlera bien sûr de la
crise sanitaire mais pas seulement
il y a également au programme le
calendrier des réformes à mener au nom
d'ici la fin du quinquennat c'est le
moment peut-être c'est l'occasion en
tout cas de s'arrêter sur ces réformes
peut-on encore en faire est ce trop tard
je vous propose comme on aime à le faire
d'un point de vue d'avoir une
instruction contradictoire
on commence par l'accusation
guillaume pelletier le député les
républicains du loir et cher expliqué ce
matin sur sud radio que le bilan s'était
zéro et qu'il allait falloir s'y mettre
d'abord présenté son bilan ou désastreux
où famélique
y a rien sur l'emploi et le chômage y a
rien sur la lutte contre l'islam
politique et le rétablissement de la
laïcité partout et pour tous donc on
voit bien que le bilan est actuellement
nul
oui j'espère et je souhaite pour mon
pays pour ma patrie que le président a
public va enfin réformé comme il l'avait
promis
notre pays donc il est temps de s'y
mettre selon le dirigeant des
républicains je propose maintenant
d'écouter un son de cloche à ces
différents puisque celui du ministre de
l'économie bruno le maire qui
répondaient par avance puisque c'était
il ya deux jours sur france inter à
guillaume pelletier en dix ans 1
on a fait de vraies réformes et 2 c'est
pas fini et il cite notamment
ça n'est pas une surprise les retraites
nous avons fait que le maquereau
transformation économique en profondeur
du pays je pense que nous avons fait
pour l'économie française davantage en
trois ans que ce qui avait été fait
depuis 20 ans que nous avions obtenu
début 2020 des résultats tout à fait
spectaculaire sur les retraites je n'ai
pas changé d'avis je considère que
globalement le pays
la france ne travaillent pas
suffisamment parce qu'il ya trop de
chômage parce qu'on fait partir trop tôt
les gens à la retraite parce que les
jeunes en trop difficilement sur le
marché du travail
alors on va pas faire le bilan ici du
quinquennat d'abord parce qu'il n'est
pas fini
ensuite parce que ce serait très long
intéressons nous plutôt à la possibilité
ou non de faire encore des réformes
claude morin sk votre avis compte tenu
de la fragilité du pays dans cette crise
sanitaire et à condition qu'on arrive à
en sortir peut-être que ça va arriver
avec les vaccins est-ce qu'on peut
encore faire des réformes ou est ce que
par exemple sur le sujet des retraites
c'est plié
moi je pense que c'est assez
étonnant qui pensent encore faire des
réformes compte tenu du fait que
l'action enfin le gouvernement est déjà
occupé à 100 % a essayé de gérer les
questions de crise sanitaire s'est un
peu pris les pieds dans le tapis avec la
stratégie vaccinale est donc on peut
s'imaginer qu'ils qu'ils auront pas te
rend fin qui pourront employer toute
leur énergie à redresser la barre et en
termes de calendrier
en fait si on regarde le temps
législatif le temps de débat
parlementaire pin qui leur reste c'est
très faible
finalement on va basculer dans là dans
la campagne présidentielle à l'automne
prochain
si on regarde le quinquennat françois
hollande après la réforme du travail du
printemps 2016 il y avait à peu près
enfin plus rien ne s'était véritablement
passé et si on regarde encore le
quinquennat d'avant c'est d'ailleurs un
élément intéressant parce que l'argument
de nicolas sarkozy c'était de dire je
n'ai pas pu réformer autant que j'avais
promis parce qu'il ya eu la crise de
2008 et en fin de campagne donc dans
février mars il avait fait plein
d'annonce pour pour montrer justement
qu'il avait encore cette volonté
réformatrice
juste avant la halle à l'échéance
électorale et personne ne le croyez à
l'époque de doucement 2012 et il s'était
heurté justement à cette difficulté qui
était que les gens disaient mais
pourquoi est ce qu on vous croirait
lorsque vous promettez de fer dans un
second quinquennat ce que vous n'avez
pas fait au premier et ça risque d'être
d'ailleurs là le problème
emmanuel macron à votre avis qui accuse
elle est ce que ils ont encore envie de
réformer ou est ce qu'ils ont envie de
prendre le moins de risques possibles
pour espérer être élu disons dans le cas
d'emmanuel mâcon ce qu'ils en ont envie
c'est un vrai sujet est-ce qu'ils le
peuvent surtout c'est surtout là le
point central c'est vrai que depuis ce
début de quinquennat
on pensait que manuel macron du fait de
sa jeunesse de sa façon de se présenter
eh bien allez être un incubateur de
réformes et en fait il a été d'une
certaine façon plutôt à un extincteur de
révolte alors y'en a qui sont de son
fait et d'autres qui ne le sont pas
c'est vrai que il est le co vie de
personnes pouvaient part il faut dire la
copie de pardon quand on est chic mais
comme je suis pas très chic je veux dire
le covin le de personne ne l'avait vu
arriver et mais c'est arrivé sur un sur
un mât comme un terrain un humus déjà de
grande intance les gilet jaune les
retraites
tout cela réactivée par des petits mots
sans doute maladroit donc imaginer
qu'après des ce terrain difficile
cette crise gérer quand même souvent
avec le pied gauche
disons le clairement au moins en terme
de communication sans doute plus du
reste mais il est évident que la
communication et est extrêmement mal pas
mal mal passé mais le seul moyen de
faire passer la pilule a été de dire à
chaque fois finalement on rasera gratis
bon voila vous inquiétez pas les
restaurateurs on va les aider le
gouvernement va les aider
là il va les aider la valise et des
lives à les aider là il va les aider
comment voulez vous revenir au un
discours sur les retraites extrêmement
strictes et tel qu'il était avant cette
crise sanitaire
alors que finalement il est apparu comme
d'une simplicité biblique d'ouvrir le
porte-monnaie donc sur ces points là je
doute fort qu'il ya une une tentative de
revues de retour réel alors on fera
peut-être dans le en même temps c'est à
dire qu'on donnera l'impression d'y
revenir sans y revenir trois pas en
avant deux pas en arrière ou l' inverse
mais ça part et ça paraît fort peu
probable donc en effet c'est difficile
d'imaginer que le quinquennat thomas
billet on peut imaginer qu'il enverra
quelques signaux c'est ce qu'il a
commencé à faire
signons un peu facile qui mange pas de
pain si j'ose dire à destination de son
électorat ou en tout cas de ce qui sera
son futur électorat ben on l'a vu sur
des réformes sociétales les réformes
sociétales c'est facile ça fait plaisir
à la gauche et c'est difficile de deux
fois il n'y a pas de comptes à rendre
c'est pas comme en économie il n'y a pas
de retour
la procréation médicalement récemment
entièrement raison et peut-être aussi
sur l'écologie parce que l'écologie
c'est sympa tout le monde va être pour
la planète on sait que c'est un
mouvement qui se porte bien actuellement
et c'est pareil ça reste assez vague on
a peu de retour on a peu de doutes id
pour vérifier l'efficacité de la
politique on n'a qu'à le voir sur les
émissions de co2 on se rend compte que
finalement le fait qu'ils aient plus de
voitures qui circulent à paris ça n'a
pas changé tant que ça
mais les embouteillages non non non
c'est parce que je veux dire c'est à
dire qu'au moment du confinement total
quand il n'y avait pas une voiture
les émissions de co2 on s'est rendu
compte que là on avait un contrôle fin
ça va pas changer grand chose au
finalement c'est s'aider des tentatives
de politique dont on mesure mal an le
les résultats qui sont peut-être
d'ailleurs tout à fait inutile comme le
monde sait ces mesures lors du continent
mais que l'on tentera je dois dire que
nos internautes partagent vos doutes on
aura posé la question sur twitter pensez
vous qu emmanuel macron puisse encore
mettre en place des réformes c'est non à
69 %
linda sur youtube et nous dînons macro
ne peut plus faire de réforme déjà
quasiment toutes celles qu'il a à
proposer ont provoqué des grèves dans
les professions concernées et des
manifestations babineau considère sur le
figaro.fr que le gouvernement n'aura ni
le temps ni l'énergie nécessaire pour
enclencher une grande réforme
et puis encore des réactions celle de
chardon bleu mc ronde ne pourraient
reprendre les réformes que si on sortait
très rapidement de cette pandémie mais
on n'en prend pas le chemin
puis quand même avec cet encouragement
d'avec respect sur le figaro.fr
il faut finaliser la réforme des
retraites alors au sommaire du séminaire
d'aujourd'hui
il y avait parmi les thèmes à aborder
l'accès à la haute fonction publique
vous souvenez-vous de ce serpent de mer
qu'est la réforme voire la suppression
de lainage propose qu'on s'y arrête
quelques minutes et en commençant par
réécouter ses propos d' emmanuel macron
c'était le 25 avril 2019 et à l'époque
pour lui cet éclair l'ena il fallait la
supprimer je pense que pour faire la
réforme que j'évoquais
il faut supprimer entre autres l'ena
mais pas pour se donner le plaisir de
supprimer l'ena pour bâtir quelque chose
qui fonctionne mieux telles que je les
dis il faudra d'ailleurs sans doute
garder les locaux les agents qui y sont
et qui sont d'excellente qualité est
profondément engagé mais je ne crois pas
sur ce sujet je ne crois pas du tout en
quelque sorte aux rafistolages à la
réforme un peu alors
donc ça c'était le projet et puis on est
arrivé quand même à ce qui semble
ressembler à une réformette puisque
effectivement il va y avoir des
changements d'école mais non seulement
elle est pas supprimé mais le classement
de sortie ne va pas être abolie c'est
simplement les critères qui permettent
de le fixer qui vont être changés et
puis nos futurs hauts fonctionnaires
feront un stage dans des pme ce qui
n'est quand même pas une révolution
clément qu'est ce qui s'est passé sur ce
sujet là qui était quand même une
réforme emblématique annoncé par un
manuel mac ont voulu parler gilet jaune
et puis c'est quoi ces c'est la haute
fonction publique ce sont les énarques
qui ont eu la peau des volontés et
réformatrices du président y ait
toujours une ambiguïté chez emmanuel
macron parce que dès sa campagne en 2016
il dénonçait une caste
il expliquait que finalement oui il
était haut fonctionnaire mais il n'était
pas comme les autres et qu' il allait
parce qu'ils connaissaient les mieux les
rouages en fait de la machine il allait
être capable de mieux la réforme et est
en fait c'est un discours qu'il a tenu
effectivement depuis près de quatre ans
en dénonçant ici l'état profond là la
caste les nantis etc
mais c'est vrai que il a promis de
supprimer les n'a alors c'est quand même
drôle quand on écoute quand on écoute
ses propos c'est en supprime l'ena mais
bon on garde les murs on garde les
personnels et puis on va pas beaucoup
changer son nom en corse est là et donc
on a le sentiment que c'est quelque
chose de très
juste très symbolique et moi à titre
personnel je pense que c'est pas le bon
symbole d'abord parce qu'il ya pas que
l'ena il ya plein d'autres grandes
écoles qui mène au grand corps est en
fait parce que les gens connaissent
l'ena parce que pas mal de président de
la république en sont sortis ou de
premier ministre et donc pour l'opinion
publique c'est vrai que c'est plus est
plus fin ça parle l'ena même si c'est de
loin donc c'est quelque chose de très
symbolique mais finalement je pense que
d'une part le la manière de recruter de
l'ena a évolué on peut pas dire le
contraire ils se sont quand même ouvert
à la fois à des catégories plus modestes
et et qui sont ils ont un peu des
parisiennes is et le recrutement alain
faut toujours aller plus loin mais je
pense de ce point de vue là qu'ils ont
fait des efforts et puis ensuite je
pense que certes c'est enfin le passage
la formation qui a dispensé à l'ina est
très importante mais après il ya toute
une partie du problème qui est dans dans
le parcours que les hauts fonctionnaires
ont ensuite c'est à dire que une fois
qu'ils ont passé leur leur concours et
c'est bruno le maire qui le dit
peut-être le mieux un 10 qui se comporte
comme une aristocratie en fait le
concours étant le privilège l'équivalent
du privilège delà de la naissance et
puis ils savent que pendant 40 ans ils
sont tranquilles et ça en fait ce n'est
pas en supprimant les nac on va le
changer donc je pense que les vraies
réformes structurelles elles sont pas
nécessairement celles là mais que c'est
quelque chose de facile à faire parce
qu'en fait ils vont pas changer il faut
pas supprimer les naïves on l'appelait
autre chose et puis ils vont changer
quelques trucs à l'intérieur c'est un
symbole pour vous cette non réforme
gabriel cluzel de la difficulté qu'a
l'état se à se réformer
oui bien sûr alors c'est vrai que c'est
un totem les nains silas avait été un
peu offert au gilet jaune sur l'autel de
la réconciliation de la semi
réconciliation fin pour intérêts
provisoirement la hache de guerre on va
dire donc c'est vrai que cette cet échec
a le nom suppression il ya le nom
anniversaire de la liste au pays des
merveilles là c'est la non suppression
de l'ena et bien c'est ce etc
ça pourrait si ça se savait parce que
finalement on le sait assez peu on a
beaucoup communiqué autour de la du
projet de suppression de l'ena on
communique beaucoup moins sur sa non
suppression atrabile d'ailleurs pas
renoncé peut-être rabin d'ailleurs oui
il a fait remarquer que beaucoup de gens
ne le savaient pas il était toujours
persuadé qu'on allait finir par
supprimer les nakhla emmanuel macron
était en train d'y travailler lorsque
c'est curieux parce qu'on entendait
toujours parler de l'ena mais si vous
vous faites des interrogés un peu votre
entourage sa nuisance est resté on est
resté dans l'idée que l'état allait être
supprimée donc c'est évidemment la cdu
en même temps on supprime sans supprimer
il est probable qu'il ya où j'imagine
vous connaissez ces sujets là mieux que
moi mais j'imagine qu'un esprit de corps
aussi il ya les laisse les énarques donc
pas envie que on déboulonne leur école
et defacto ce qu'il est ce qu'ils sont
et ce qu'ils représentent
non ce qui est intéressant est ce qui
devrait quand même interrogé c'est que
il ya d'autres écoles d'excellence
polytechnique normale sup et aidera qui
ne suscite pas la même crise passion et
la même détestation il faut peut-être se
demander pourquoi et pourtant il ya eu
des présidents giscard était et est
polytechnicien pour ne citer que lui bon
mais en l'ena suscite une détestation
parce que les gens ont l'impression que
ce n'est pas par le mérite comme c'est
les autres écoles dont ils font certains
méritent sans toutefois rentrer à l'ena
pour réussir ce concours donc la
difficulté c'est que si on change les
règles du jeu en supprimant le mérite
c'est à dire parce que malheureusement
sait très bien qu'aujourd'hui quand on
commence à rentrer dans des politiques
où on regarde plus les gens
individuellement mais on se dit est ce
qu'il vient de tels quartiers ce qui
vient de là est ce que on le mérite peut
être mis à mal un feu sous couvert
d'égalitarisme en fait on abîme
l'égalité eh bien ça pourrait enlever
quelque chose qui permettait quand même
de faire les lettres de noblesse de
l'ena et et le rendre dans une école
d'entre eux soient ou non rendre par
cooptation voyez comme par exemple dans
la magistrature
on sait très bien qu'aujourd'hui un
certain nombre de magistrats qui sont
entrés sur dossier on dit oui malheureux
ça a été un peu c'est un peu par
cooptation voilà bien un concours comme
maintenant pour entrer à l'école
nationale de la magistrature
oui mais vous savez très bien que il ya
un certain nombre de gens qui sont
rentrés d'une façon différente que le
petit étudiant les différents moyens
voilà et on croit que plus plus ses
moyens se multiplient et plus le quidam
moyen justement a le sentiment que il ya
des chemins de traverse où il vaut mieux
connaître du monde pour y accéder alors
là ça atteint prodigieusement la
conscience la confiance assez pour y
entrer mais c'est surtout en réalité ce
que ce qui se fait à l'ena est ce qu
ensuite deviennent les énarques qui qui
blessent les français c'est à dire
qu'ils ont l'impression que ces gens là
sont complètement hors sol et on est en
effet c'est pas un stage dans une pme
qui va changer la face du monde et cela
pour le moment on voit rien venir sur
ces sujets là voilà nicole 06 est assez
d'accord sur lefigaro.fr le problème de
l'ena n'est pas l'origine des étudiants
mais le fait qu'ils sortent tous
formatés
de la même manière plus ou moins d'un
point de vue politique
vous pensez que emmanuel macron a plus à
perdre qu'à gagner à continuer les
réformes
il a quand même été élu en 2010 est sûre
sur cet élan réformateur est ce que
c'est pas un bon moyen de faire revenir
les électeurs que de dire regardez je
n'ai pas renoncé à transformer le pays
là il est vraiment devant un dilemme
c'est à dire que l'aspiration profonde
d'une grande majorité des gens
aujourd'hui c'est quand même d'être
mieux protégés de tous les points de vue
d'ailleurs autant sur le plan
sécuritaire par rapport au terrorisme
que sur le plan économique parce qu'on
on est quand même qu'au tout début d'une
crise économique qui est qui s'annonce
majeure donc la protection et puis une
forme d'apaisement on a incité alléger
les jaunes les manifestations il ya un
an tout juste qui était quand même assez
assez nombreuses et violentes sur sur la
réforme des retraites donc je pense
qu'il ya un désir dans la société à la
fois de protection et d'apaisement et
que ce sera quand même les dominantes de
la campagne présidentielle
mais lorsqu'on revient à emmanuel macron
lui-même à son adn politique qui est
quand même le mouvement la réforme alors
la réforme c'est très vague mais c'est
pour ça que c'est plus un mouvement
enfin le sentiment qui fait quelque
chose et qui battu c'est exactement ça
et puis son socle c'est plutôt des gens
qui sont allés vers vers ce candidat là
pour faire changer les choses est plutôt
dans un sens et ben économiquement plus
libérale en fait et donc la question
c'est est ce que il va renouer pour pour
mobiliser son socle renouer avec cet adn
là au risque de fracture et une société
qui est quand même déjà un peu à bout
surtout de tous les points de vue ou est
ce que au contraire il va essayer de de
coller aux aspirations beaucoup plus
large de l'ensemble de la société donc
protection réconciliation mais là en
fait c'est pas le mieux placé pour faire
ça s'est passé pas son truc quoi la
réconciliation d'ailleurs il a plutôt
été celui qui qui provoquait qui clivent
est bien plus souvent qui n'a
réconcilier et à mon avis ce dilemme que
vous venez d'évoquer il est au coeur des
discussions du séminaire d'aujourd'hui
je laisse le dernier mot arômes 37 91
sur lefigaro.fr le problème nous dit il
ce n'est pas que les nas est aussi les
français qui depuis 1969 réforme tout
refuse toutes les réformes 69 c'est
peut-être le référendum de la femme du
sénat a voulu par le général de gaulle
c'est possible mais c'est promis je me
reposerai dans mes notes aprilia ne vois
pas d'autres événements majeurs cette
année l'a écouté le débat est ouvert
je vous parliez à l'instant que et morin
d'une société qui n'allait pas bien
c'est l'occasion de revenir sur ses
déclarations ce matin de jean françois
delfraissy le président du conseil
scientifique
il a mis la focale le projecteur plutôt
sur des gens dont on parle peut-être pas
suffisamment dans cette crise sanitaire
les étudiants et le retentissement
sociétal psychiques chez nos jeunes
étudiants est un problème majeur qui est
aussi sanitaire d'ailleurs disions le
niveau d'anxiété le niveau de dépression
particulier chez les étudiants en
première année qui n'ont pas eu de
contact je dirais présentiel avec avec
leur leurs camarades est un problème
majeur donc il faut tout faire pour
qu'on puisse reprendre en présentiel
une partie de l'activité des étudiants
de l'enseignement supérieur à partir des
vacances de février pour le deuxième
semestre de l'année universitaire et
comme en écho à ce cri d'alarmé il ya
cette lettre ouverte envoyée au
président de la république par une
étudiante de sciences po strasbourg
avait dissout peau qui dit notamment la
réalité c'est que je n'ai plus de rêve
tous mes projets s'écroulent les uns
après les autres au même rythme que mon
moral décline gabriel cluzel je vais me
faire l'avocat du diable mais les
étudiants c'est quand même pas les gens
qui sont les plus frappés par cette
pandémie parce que d'un point de vue
sanitaire ils risquent quasiment rien
quand on est jeune le coc vite c'est pas
grave
d'ailleurs ils restent plus ou moins
sérieusement les consignes sanitaires
alors c'est vrai ils peuvent pas être en
cours de façon physique mais il ya des
millions de salariés qui lui aussi
travaille à distance alors est ce qu'ils
sont vraiment aussi à plaindre que ça
alors c'est à plaindre je sais pas si
c'est le mot ce qui est certain c'est
qu'il faut changer les choses absolument
alors c'est vrai que j'entends beaucoup
je lis beaucoup ici et là des gens dire
aux baous qu'est ce qui devrait dire
s'il était de la génération de la guerre
14 dans les tranchées alors c'est
toujours un peu amusant parce que c'est
la génération 2
j'entends aussi des jeunes leur répondre
attendez vous êtes de la génération des
baby boomers qui avait jamais vu la
guerre et qui avait connu liberté sans
pareille sur tous les plans et une
économie florissante qui venait nous
dire que quand même un regard des dégâts
dans les tranchées c'était quand même
autre chose
non je crois qu'il ya un vrai une vraie
détresse à prendre en compte un je crois
que c'est le praticien du médecin qui
disait au mois de décembre il y avait
deux fois plus de syndrome anxio
dépressifs chez les 16 25 ans donc c'est
pas rien et on voit aussi le professeur
delfraissy dit ça c'est aussi parce
qu'il sait qu'il ya des jeunes qui se
sont suicidés enfin il ya un certain
nombre de choses alors c'est une vie
sociale les quand on est étudiant ces
moments là vie sociale se déploie en
déploie ses ailes et c'est une vie
sociale qui n'existe plus mais ya pas
que ça c'est une perspective économique
on sait bien que les étudiants du mal à
décrocher des stages actuellement c'est
des perspectives de travail on est en
plus dans des dents des comment dire
dans dans un récit narratif si j'ose
dire apocalyptique quand même hein c'est
à dire que depuis un an
c'est là où on voit tous les prophètes
philippulus de la terre des finales la
télévision en nous disant que c'était
pas bien hier mais ce sera encore pire
demain donc il est évident que sur des
dvd des étudiants qui ne sont pas encore
adultes qui ne peuvent pas échangé qui
ne peuvent pas ce sont des enfants des
étudiants enseignants parlait autrefois
des enfants du placard pour parler des
enfants maltraités ces enfants qui
restés chez eux on se rend des comptes
ils avaient été maltraités par leurs
parents les sortait jamais ben y avait
des vrais troubles psychologiques
là je crois que c'est c'est un petit peu
la même chose sans exagérer évidemment
mais c'est évidemment à prendre en
compte
pendant quinze jours on peut leur faire
un chantage une manière de chantage
affectif c'est à dire leur dire vous
allez sauver le pays en restant dans
votre canapé
mais là ça va faire un an que ça dure
c'est en effet je crois sérieusement à
prendre en compte c'est ce que qu'on se
donne aux internautes aussi dans l'art
très large majorité de vous posons la
question sur twitter comprenez vous le
mal-être les étudiants face à la
situation et 83%
des participants à notre questionnaire
qui n'est pas un sondage puisque vous
n'êtes pas forcément un échantillon
représentatif de la population française
vous êtes l'élite puisque vous regardez
point de vue voilà ce que vous
considérez puis cette réaction de q cela
sur youtube on les empêche d'avoir une
vie normale et on les culpabilise sur
une éventuelle contamination de leurs
proches
claude brun en principe la jeunesse
c'est l'âge de tous les possibles c'est
aussi l'âge de forme d'insouciance
pourquoi à votre avis est ce que les
étudiants sont semble-t-il
collectivement si plombé par ce qui se
passe ils ne sont pas résilient pour
employer un terme de psychologie en
vogue
je pense qu'il ya deux choses il ya
effectivement le fait de vivre confiné
au moment où on a peut-être la vie
sociale la plus intense en théorie
souvent dans des conditions
enfin les chambres d'étudiants c'est ce
que c'est vivre confiné dans quinze
mètres carrés 20 mètres carrés c'est
évidemment papa est pas évident mais il
ya à ça un facteur économique qui
s'ajoute rien que j'avais vu une étude
en 2016 on avait déjà 20 % des étudiants
qui étaient sous le seuil de pauvreté
là toutes les associations avec le co
vide disent qu'ils ont vu exploser la
pauvreté des étudiants notamment parce
qu'il n'y a pas de petits boulots ya pas
de boulot de serveur il n'y a pas eu de
boulots saisonniers non plus donc pour
une partie d'entre eux sada engendre des
conditions de vie qui sont qui sont
extrêmement difficile ils sont passés
directement du de la case resto u aux
restos du coeur quoi c'est et donc
forcément ça pèse sur le moral et il ya
eu des estimations on a à peu près un
tiers qui sont en situation de stress de
souffrance psychique donc c'est pas
négligeable
et la question que ça pose c'est à long
terme qu'est ce que ça va engendrer est
ce qu'il y aura des aces qui garderont
des traces de ceux là sur le plan
économique on sait que par exemple les
étudiants qui commencent leur vie
professionnelle dans une crise
économique porte cela en terme de
salaire moindre
pendant des années des années donc ça a
été mesurée on sait que déjà ils vont
être probablement pénalisé par la crise
économique
il ya cet effet psychologique qui
s'ajoute non pas ce qui m'était ce qui
m'étonne c'est que le gouvernement a
vraiment fait de la volonté de remettre
les enfants à l'école
un symbole vraiment on voit qu'il y en a
pas mal de nos voisins d'ailleurs qui
ont refermé les écoles nous on dit il
faut absolument pour les enfants de les
laisser à l'école j'ai reçu plein coeur
en parlait d'ailleurs au grand jury
dimanche
je m'en souviens parce que c'est moi qui
lui ai posé la question et il était fier
de ça en dix ans en france nous avons
voulu ouvrir les écoles et et tout le
monde regarde comment on a fait et si
c'est paradoxal de voir à côté
qu'effectivement il ya cette espèce de
2,2 points aveugles avec un discours
assez faible sur les
étudiants et puis pas pas vraiment de
perspective de reprise des cours depuis
en tout cas depuis depuis quasiment un
an on arrive à une situation assez qu
est ce que moi je vis parce que je des
enfants d'âge divers où les grands
restent h avec maman et papa tel le
tanguy moyens et où plus on lâche des
croix c'est à dire que alors là on
classe primaire
on travaille beaucoup et c'est vrai que
ça a quelque chose d extrêmement
étonnant alors ça peut justifier par le
fait qu'effectivement il ya des classes
on peut pas suivre un enseignement par
internet ne soit dûment numérique mais
néanmoins les faits et
est absolument curieux et je pense à
long terme délétère la question qu'on
peut se poser un peu cyniquement c'est
de se dire finalement est ce que ce
gouvernement qui est quand même dans
dans un cadre où on craint les des
retours judiciaire enfin une
judiciarisation de la société il ya déjà
des plaintes au dessus de sa tête comme
une épée de damoclès est ce que il se
dit pas bon finalement on gère à court
terme les risques quantifiable c'est à
dire que c'est à dire les morts directs
du lait les les chiffres des morts dues
au vide direct et puis finalement on
s'intéresse moins à ce qui n'est pas
quantifiable ou moins quantifiable ou
dont on sera moins redevable parce que
c'est des risques plus indirecte parce
que c'est vrai que cette génération qui
aura des prix mais pour chacune alors
évidemment il ya toutes sortes de jeunes
dont il ya eu des choses différentes que
les répercussions sont pas les mêmes ce
sera difficile difficilement
quantifiable on s'en rendra peut-être
compte dans trois ans dans cinq ans dans
dix ans est ce qu'on pourra vraiment
l'attribué à cette crise c'est une
question qui se pose alors peut-être que
le principe de précaution finalement ne
se ne s'intéresse et ne fait que l'on
s'intéresse par ricochet que aux risques
extrêmement direct et immédiat et pas
ceux là qui sont plus lointains vous
pensez que le gouvernement en fait trop
claude morin sur sur les étudiants que
par exemple on pourrait les autoriser à
à revenir en fac a monté un petit peu le
niveau des jauges comme on dit
aujourd'hui peut-être ou peut-être un
par petits groupes ou en tout cas je ne
sais pas je suis pas au fait de toutes
les discussions qui a au sein du
gouvernement mais j'ai le sentiment qui
n'a pas vraiment cette volonté de
chercher des modalités de de retour
alors que l'on sait bien que par exemple
pour pour l'école il ya différentes
options il y avait l'option où il y
avait des élèves par moitié de classe ou
je sais pas quoi et qu'y qui tournait
pour justement qui est pas trop d'élèves
dans la même classe en même temps enfin
bref on peut tout inventé et donc
pourquoi est-ce qu'on peut inventer des
choses jusqu'au lycée et puis on
pourrait pas inventer des choses pour
pour les étudiants on peut imaginer
qu'on va pas remplir des amphis là
maintenant tout de suite mais enfin pour
les td
exemple peut imaginer que au lieu d'être
20 ou 30 et en coupant de jeu
j'en sais rien mais on a l'impression
qu'il ya vraiment pas de volonté
d'inventer des choses ce qu'on dit aussi
mais quand les caméras sont fermés c'est
que il ya une ministre de l'enseignement
supérieur frédéric vidal qui n'est
peut-être pas aussi offensif que le sont
d'autres ministres pour défendre les
intérêts dont elle a la charge je vous
livre c'est point de vue de nos
internautes
martin poulard sur youtube qui ça fait
quoi ce que vous venez de dire qu'ils
considèrent que nos gouvernements total
nos gouvernants pardon totalement
délaissé la question des étudiants et
puis ken tuango sur youtube
le coc vis de nous enferme c'est vrai on
s'enfonce dans une routine effrayante
avec les conséquences psychologiques qui
vont avec
en plus de ça notre génération fait face
à un avenir incertain
ce virus ne sera sûrement derrière lui
une crise économique de new subiront les
conséquences
tout ça n'est pas très réjouissant
heureusement il ya christian léon
toussaint sur lefigaro.fr qui dit mais
non il ne faut pas les plaindre ils
doivent assumer comme toute la
population mondiale
ce combat contre le coc vide
est ce que vous pensez gabriel cluzel
que cette psychologie collective
elle est aujourd'hui stabilisé ces
tacots les gens ou en quelque sorte
développer une forme de résignation ou
bien s'il ya d'autres mesures qui arrive
de couvre feu généralisé autres
confinement le climat collectif peut
encore se dégrader
il ya une forme de résignation qui est
indéniable jeu d'ailleurs elle est assez
surprenante mais elle est quand on en
parle avec certains certains
psychologues ils disent que c'est une
phase assez normal de cette forme de
résiliation de se dire de toute façon
c'est comme ça on peut pas faire
autrement
moi je pense pour revenir aux jeunes que
il y aura des conséquences à long terme
du fait d'avoir c'est l'âge où on se
forge un peu les notions de bien et de
mal d'avoir d'une certaine façon
criminaliser la socialisation c'est à
dire que actuellement lardy le crime
c'est de se voir ces deux de se
rencontrer de se mêler les uns aux
autres ces voix là nous on ouvrait on
nous disait plutôt que
ce qui n'était pas bien c'était délaissé
ses grands parents on leur dit que
finalement il faut pas et c'est bien de
ne pas aller les voir donc on peut on
peut imaginer que ça laissera des traces
après cette résignation on l'a vu pour
dans d'autres cadres historiques qui ne
sont pas ceux des cracks crise sanitaire
même par exemple des régimes et
autoritaire et aidera qu'elle parfois
elle est suivie d'une phase de grande de
fortes gronde
parce que la résignation at un point
paroxystique et redescend donc c'est
vrai que c'est des points sur lesquels
je pense un gouvernement responsable
doit être vigilant voilà et probablement
que le premier ministre a en tête ces
éléments de réflexion puisque nous
attendons demain d'éventuelles nouvelles
mesures de contrainte dans la crise
sanitaire merci beaucoup à tout les deux
merci à vous de nous avoir suivis point
de vue c'est fini pour ce soir mais ça
recommence demain c'est promis même
heure même endroit
[Musique]